[Music]
happy Victory there let's get on with it
please
yes
ravishing I mean the flowers are
ravishing I just need to be brief for
these
briefings Madam Chancellor Corporal
zubac not nice what they're calling you
butcher there's a good man in there who
deserves
love the chancellor has than if
situation he's not dangerous is
[Music]
he she'll lose interest she always does
H what if this time she doesn't I'd love
to swash their faces anyone who makes
you
weak Madam Chancellor let's keep the
gloves on this is not a confrontation
we're just saying what's
true this is emphatically not business
as usual the protest will only spread I
want more you should have more your
people DET turning on you madam sit down
sit down piece of advice why don't I
just smash your face in well if you
think it'll help you will need to be
better at being normal when you're not
normal it makes me feel like you're
telling me that I'm not normal which
makes me distrust all of you and want
you to be dead so just be better at
being
normal anyone who dares in insult me or
my country shall feel my
Fury Madam if you are indeed proposing
an invasion no one is proposing an
invasion no one call it an expression of
peace and
love something like that something fun
Snappy yep
[Music]
good